YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
KNEE-JERK REACTIONS, WHENEVER
A CAMERA ENDS UP CATCHING A
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE OR AN
ATHLETE AT ANY LEVEL, IS THE
HI MOM. AND SINCE YESTERDAY
WAS MOTHER'S DAY, TODAY'S
DRAFT IS THE BEST MUGGING FOR
THE CAMERA MOMENT.
SPECIFICALLY PLAYER COMMENTS
THAT WE WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER
MADE INTO A CAMERA ANYPLACE.
ANYTIME ANYWHERE. CHRIS
TRIVIA QUESTION THAT I JUST
THOUGHT OF THAT, I KNOW YOU
WILL APPRECIATE IN WHICH STATE
OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. DID MOTHER'S DAY
ORIGINATED WOO-WIT STATE. I
DIDN'T KNOW THIS. SO THIS
ORIGINATED IN A STATE, OKAY.
WHERE WOULD THIS IS THERE? NO
LOGIC TO THIS AT ALL. IS IT
TOTALLY? LIKE, IS THERE ANY
LITTLE LOGIC TO A LOGIC TO
LOGIC? YEAH, BEEN LITTLE BIT.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I'M GONNA
SAY NEW JERSEY SINCE I'M FROM
NEW JERSEY. YEAH, RIGHT IDEA.
YEAH IT'S WASHER IS U4J. I .
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN IT COMES
BACK TO YOU. OF COURSE IT DID.
COME BACK TIMES. GIVING YOU
A QUOTE WHAT? WAIT A MINUTE.
THAT'S THE ONE FACT THAT I
KNOW ABOUT MOTHER'S DAY. ANNA,
JARVIS STARTED MOTHER'S DAY
IN 1907 WITHIN FIVE YEARS.
MOTHER'S DAY. SO, YES, JUST
UP THE ROAD. I THINK IT WAS
IN GRAFTON WEST VIRGINIA.
ANNA JARVIS STARTED MOTHER'S
DAY SO I
RIGHT. I LIKE IT. THAT WAS
GOOD. THAT WAS A NICE LITTLE
PERSONAL, RIGHT? CHURCH WRONG
PEW. GOOD GOOD. I LIKED IT.
ALL RIGHT. THE, YOU KNOW, THE
FIRST ONE FOR ME, EVEN THOUGH
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN ANYWHERE
CLOSE TO A FIELD. YEAH.
IT'S GOT TO BE AND AND THERE
ARE LIKE THREE OR FOUR
DIFFERENT ITEMS FROM IT. WE
WILL ALWAYS BE KNOWN AS THE
STRAIGHT CASH HOMIE MOMENT
FROM RANDY MOSS. LET'S GO
AHEAD AND SEE HOW MUCH OF IT
WE CAN REALLY AND TRULY
APPRECIATE AFTER HE WAS AFTER
HE WAS FINED FOR PRETENDING
TO MOON THE CROWD AT LAMBEAU
FIELD. HE WAS CHASED TO HIS
TRUCK BY REPORTERS AND HE
GAVE ONE OF THE ALL-TIME
RIGHT CHICK.
HOW DO YOU PAY MAN? IF YOU
DON'T WRITE CHECKS, HOW DO
YOU PAY THESE GUYS, RIGHT?
CASH ONLY
CRAZY. WERE YOU UPSET?
ND?
THERE'S MORE, THERE'S MORE GO
TO YOUTUBE, THERE'S MORE THAT
YOU WANT TO COLLECT THAT LAST
THAT LAST TIME, I LIKE WHAT
IT SAYS, AT THE END I COULD
NEXT TIME. YOUTUBE.COM, E
THAT'S MY PICK. I'M GOING TO
GOOD ONE THOUGH. I DO LIKE  A
THAT. A WHOLE LOT. OF COURSE,
RANDY IS HILARIOUS. LIKE HE D
REALLY IS, I JUST BEING
AROUND THEM A LITTLE BIT. IN
CAREER I COULD TOTALLY SEE
RIGHT FOR ME, YOU KNOW, ONE
OF THE, THE ONE THAT ALWAYS
JUMPS OUT TO MY BRAIN MORE
THAN ANY, RIGHT? JUST AS FAR
AS LIKE WHEN I WAS GROWING UP,
THE SHANNON SHARPE ON THE
SIDELINES IN FOXBOROUGH
AGAINST THE PATRIOTS, CALL
THE NATIONAL GUARD BECAUSE
THE PATRIOTS NEED HELP. WE
ARE WHAT DOES HE SAY? WE'RE
KILLING KILLING THE GREAT
HILL. IN THE PATRIOTS, SEND
THE NATIONAL GUARD ALL OF
BELIEVABLE MOMENT AND I THINK
WOULD ALSO LIKE MAKES IT
LET'S SEE THAT YEAR. LET'S
SEE. THAT WAS THE YEAR. THE
BRONCOS WHAT LOST IN THE TO
JACKSONVILLE, RIGHT? AND THE
DIVISIONAL PLAYOFF GAME
UPSETTING, THEY WERE THE BEST
TEAM IN THE LEAGUE THAT YEAR
BUT THAT'S A PRETTY AWESOME
MOMENT BY SHANNON SHARPE.
YEAH, THAT WAS AT THE OLD
PATRIOTS STADIUM AND HE'S
HAVING FUN AS THEY WERE
KICKING THE CRAP OUT OF THE
PATRIOTS AT DAY, AND YES,
THEY GOT STUNNED BY THE
JAGUARS. BUT THEN ONE, THE
NEXT TWO IN A ROW. I LIKE
THAT ONE. I
THAT ONE. I LIKE THAT. AND
THAT'S WHERE I'M GOING NEXT.
DAMN, MINNESOTA OVER HERE. SO
MY HE WAS PLAYING FOR
WASHINGTON AND THAT SQUEAKY
PETER, BRADY TOM TO CHANGE
VOICE COMING OFF THE FIELD.
DO WE HAVE? HERE WE GO. YOU
CAN HEAR IT AGAIN FOR
YOURSELF KIRK COUSINS. WE
I LOVE IT. ECHO
, AWESOME. YEAH, THAT WAS
PERSONAL. YEAH, YOU KNOW,
SOME DEMONS. HE TRIED, HE ING
TRIED SOMETHING LIKE A NEW.
WE AT ONE POINT TO BUT THE
YEAH, YOU LIKE THAT. YOU LIKE
THAT IS NUMBER ONE, BOWIE IS
NOW THAT WAS THAT WAS PRETTY
DAMN SPECIAL. I MEAN THAT WAS
A PRETTY COOL MOMENT BY KIRK
COUSINS. HE'S NOT THE KIND OF
GUY THAT SHOWS THAT TYPE OF
EMOTION
OUR YELLS AT A CAMERA OR DOES
THAT TYPE OF STUFF? BUT THAT
A CRUCIAL PART OF HIS CAREER.
HE MADE A WHAT WAS THAT?
LIKE A LAST SECOND TOUCHDOWN?
AGAINST THE BUCKS, RIGHT? AND
SOME GAME THERE, AND THEN
YOU LIKE THAT ENDED UP TO.
YEAH, YOU LIKE THAT. YOU LOVE
ME. I'M ON YOUR TEAM. THE
VIKINGS, WHOOP.
ALRIGHT, MY NEXT ONE HERE
AND I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE
GOING TO BE ROLE OF THIS ONE
FILMS CLASSIC HERE, RIGHT?
BUT I KNOW, YOU'LL KNOW THIS
ONE ANYBODY THAT'S WATCHING
NFL FILMS.
THEY LIKE LAWRENCE TAYLOR ON
THE SIDELINES OF A 1984
PRESEASON GAME. YOU KNOW, THE
ONE WHERE HE'S IT'S GOING
DOWN LIKE A BUNCH OF CRAZED.
HAVE SOME FUN AND, YOU KNOW,
AND THEN HE'S THEY GOT A
MIC'D UP AND HE'S TACKLING
KENNY O'BRIEN. HE'S GOING,
SON, Y'ALL GOT TO DO BETTER
MOMENTS LIKE A PSYCHO ON THE
SIDELINES. THAT WAS MY EVEN
TEAM THAT WAS MY FIRST R THE
EXPERIENCE OF KNOWING THAT MY
DAD'S TEAMMATE WAS A PSYCHO.
I CAN STILL REMEMBER BEING A
WHO IS THIS GUY? 56 IS
AMAZING AND HE YELLS AND DOES
ALL THAT STUFF. BUT JUST LIKE
THE PERSONALITY OF LAWRENCE
TAYLOR AND GOING OFF ON THE
SIDELINES TO ME AS ONE OF
THOSE GREAT. HI MOM MOMENTS.
AND THAT WAS A PRESEASON
THAT WE GOT LIKE A PACKER
CRAZED DOGS PRESEASON GAME
AGAINST THE JETS, RIGHT?
THAT'S HOW CRAZY LAWRENCE
TAYLOR IS. SO, THERE WAS A
POINT WHERE THE GIANTS TOOK
THAT GAME AS SERIOUSLY AS THE
JETS. ONCE DID, REMEMBER,
WHEN REX RYAN PUT MARK,
SANCHEZ BACK IN THE GAME AND
GOT HIM INJURED BECAUSE THEY
POOPY TROPHY. I KNOW. YES. OH
THOSE ARE SOME OF MY DAD'S
BEST WAR. STORIES IS LIKE
THAT PRESEASON GAME NUMBER
THREE AGAINST THE JETS. HE
OH, MAN, MARK GASTINEAU AND ,
THAT DEFENSE, AND IT WAS THE
FIRST LIVE, LIKE, LET'S HAVE
A REAL GAME TYPE OF MOMENT,
AND I THINK DAD'S GOT A FEW
BATTLE SCARS ON HIS BODY FROM
SOME OF THOSE PRESEASON
GAMES STILL OR BATTLE SCARS
BATTLE SCARS SCORES. BUT I'M
GONNA JETS AND THEY KNOW WHO
WE MEAN BART, SCOTT SOUTH
SOUTH PAOLANTONIO AFTER
READY TO TAKE ON THE PATRIOTS,
BACK IN 2010, A GAME THAT
THE JETS WOULD WIN. CAN'T
WAIT, WAS BART SCOTT? I LOVE
IT. THERE IT IS. CAN'T WAIT.
OKAY, WAIT CAN'T WAIT, SOUNDS
LIKE THAT'S IT. THERE'S MORE
YOU'RE LEAVING. THAT'S IT.
THAT'S GOOD. THAT'S ENOUGH,
WAIT. AWESOME, CAN'T WAIT
THAT. LET'S SEE. WAS THAT THE
YEAR? THEY WENT TO THE COLTS
OR THEY GO TO THE THAT WAS
AFTER THEY BEAT THE PACE
DEALERS, IT WAS ACTUALLY
BEAT THE PATRIOTS. YEAH. YEAH.
CAN'T WAIT, CAN'T WAIT. IT
WOULD HELP IF I PROPERLY NEW
NEW THE CONTEXT OF ONE OF MY
GREAT QUOTES IT WAS AFTER
THEY BEAT THE PATRIOTS. YEAH.
THEN THEY WENT. THEN THEY
WENT TO. YEP. THEY BEAT THEM
MANNING BEAT BRADY. AND THEN
THEY COULDN'T BEAT BIG BEN &
COMPANY IN THE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME. ALL RIGHT.
MAMA. I'M THE LAST ONE. I
MEAN, I'M GOING TO A SPECIAL
MOMENT IN THE SIMS FAMILY
HISTORY. I MEAN, YES. I MEAN
YOU TALK ABOUT HI, MOM
MOMENTS AND MY DAD DID, YOU
KNOW I'M GOING TO DISNEY
WORLD. HE WAS THE FIRST GUY
EVER TO DO THAT. I'M GONNA
WORLD. LOOK THERE. I AM. I'M
AT DISNEYWORLD. LOOK AT THAT.
LOOK AT THAT. HEY, MOM, I
WANT TO CUT THE LINE AND GO
ON SPACE MOUNTAIN. THE HELL
WITH ALL THESE PEOPLE? I WANT
TO COME AND WATCH ONE, IS YOU
THE BRONZE ON THE BOTTOM, THE
PHIL SAID, HE'S MY COUSIN.
ME. MY COUSIN JOSH. YEP. BUT
THINK THAT WAS DISNEYLAND AT
THIS POINT RIGHT HERE, THAT
WE ENDED UP GOING TO, BUT
YEAH, PRETTY AWESOME. BIG.
THAT. I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE
GOT PAID. BUT
IT WAS PRETTY AWESOME MOMENT
IN OUR LIFE AT LEAST. DO YOU
REMEMBER? WHAT RIDES WHAT
RIDES DID YOU GO ON? I MEAN,
THAT II THINK LIKE, YOU KNOW,
WHAT IS IT NOT SPLASH THE
THUNDER MOUNTAIN, RIGHT?
THAT WAS LIKE, THUNDER
MOUNTAIN IS SPACE MOUNTAIN
WHEN I WAS THAT AGE. I MEAN,
COME ON NOW WAS AS COOL AS IT
GOT. I WAS A LITTLE TOO OLD
FOR JUST LIKE THE LIKE MICKEY
MOUSE GOING IN A CIRCLE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. SO I
KNOW I PICTURE YOU ON THE
TEACUPS, I PICKED YOU ON THE
TEACUPS, I PICTURE YOU ON THE
TEACUPS AND THEN STOMACH IN
ON SOME
HEY MOM,
CURSING THEM OUT FOR GETTING
IN THE WAY OF YOUR NEVERMIND.
ALRIGHT LET'S TAKE A BREAK OR
WRAP UP THIS MONDAY EDITION
50 LIBRARY. AFTER THIS. OH MY
GOSH. THAT'S CRAZY.
LOOK AT DIRTY DIANA.